[Music]
foreign
we're live now hey everyone thank you so
much for tuning in to this live stream
I'm here today with John co-founder of
tutorials dojo and we're here today to
share our advice on how to Ace your next
AWS certification exam so John will also
be sharing his top tips on how Cloud
Learners can use their AWS skills to
improve their career through Contracting
freelancing and other side hustles so
really exciting live stream today and
for those tuning in live we'll be
announcing a giveaway very soon that you
can participate in there's around 50
tutorials Dojo resources that we'll be
giving out for free and these include
video courses practice exams and ebooks
welcome to the live stream John how are
you doing today thanks Lucy thanks for
having me and hi everyone from I think I
see everyone here from the Philippines
Australia Toronto India what's else so
yeah hello everyone and also from South
Africa hey
thank you for having me thank you for
coming in
thanks for being here I'm just reading
the comments now as well so for those
joining please let us know what you're
cheating in from uh maybe what time it
is over there for you because I know a
lot of you ended up staying up late or
waking up early for the live stream so
we really really appreciate it
um so John I started my AWS
certification Journey around two and a
half years ago and back then I remember
so many people were wearing tutorials
Dojo resources to me and said that it
was the best place to do any best
practice exams and since then you know
you've helped so many Cloud Learners
pass their AWS certification exams so
I'm sure a lot of the audience are quite
familiar uh with tutorials dojo and uh
you know all the resources that you've
been providing to the community so for
those who don't know you and for those
who are maybe new to 80 certifications
do you want to share a bit about your
journey with tutorials dojo and just how
you've been able to help people with
learning AWS Cloud Sure so again hi
everyone I'm John bonser I'm the
co-founder of the Taurus Dojo we're an
AWS training partner with digital
capability that means we provide free
courses and of course a premium courses
for video course let's say video courses
practice exams ebooks and such and well
just a quick uh information about me uh
I'm originally from the Philippines yes
and then I migrated to Australia and
then right now actually back in the
Philippines but managing our offshore
team here in the Philippines so uh let's
let Lucy mentioned
um I started off my career like way back
in 2007 I was a Java developer back then
you know and then before I worked here
in the Philippines for after graduation
uh so again the whole thing about them
is like Java right Java certification
Cisco certification and certifications
back then is quite a big thing
and then I work in Singapore for three
years and after what I went to Australia
and in all those transitions you know uh
I and there's a lot of employers that I
work with uh it's a total of 12 or over
12 companies did you believe that 12
companies in three different countries
so I can provide some feedback and of
course my personal experience is on how
powerful those certifications are and of
course
um during those times when I was in
Australia in Sydney
um I started you moved my grade there
moved there on 2014 so 2014 2015 2016.
back then I was um I got my permanent
residency so I was able to have my own
personal job and then at my day job and
at night I'm doing online courses as
mentioned I was a Java developer back
then uh but in Sydney you know times has
changed it's now JavaScript so people
are talking about angular rehack and
also all of those things so I have to
adapt so that's why I became a full
stack developer doing JavaScript
typescript and everything uh so I've
done a lot of Contracting as well
um and I'm a go-getter so for
Contracting it's quite different in
probably in probably in the Philippines
or in Australia or in the US or in a
different country in Australia you have
this called uh per day or contract
contract rate meaning they can provide
you uh let's say 700 per day grow
or even as much as one thousand dollars
Australian dollars per day so this is
big for Contracting so I used to work
with you know I want to believe it again
it's all companies different companies I
work with Telstra I work with woolies I
work with uh Macquarie Bank those big
Australian companies even for loose
Corporation this Corp for media so it's
quite a lot different companies uh
different setup and of course of course
different needs
um again and after that in 20 uh 2019 I
actually left the corporate world
started my own business with the tourist
dojo and
um right now um we're over over half a
million uh users and subscribers for the
tourist Dojo so that's a quick thing
about me
that's amazing so what I'm gonna do now
is I'm a lot of people are starting to
ask about the uh you know the giveaway
and a lot of people are here for the
giveaways
yeah I'll just quickly share the slides
you know before people keep asking
um so here okay let me just see here is
the QR code that uh people can use to
join the giveaway
um you know for the free resources and
I'll just pop a link in the chat uh
before we continue our convo uh but yeah
thanks so much for sharing your career
journey I really like how you mentioned
that sometimes you know Tech evolves
really quickly you know you started off
you know you were involved with like
JavaScript and JavaScript courses but
then you realize that you know Cloud
became really big and there was a huge
demand for cloud so it's really
important to adapt in your career and we
can talk more about this later when we
talk about you know how to improve a
cloud career and your Tech Career in
2023 when we provide advice to people uh
but yeah really good takeaway there ever
just from the start of the live stream
so for those watching please pop in your
questions into the chat and we'll get
back to them as we go along in the live
stream but first of all I like to focus
on some of the questions that we have
right here on the screen which some of
the questions the viewers have been
submitting and I've just collated a list
of the most frequently asked questions
that people want answers to so John uh
first question I want to ask and I've
gotten this question a lot and sometimes
I'm not really sure what you know the
correct answer is because I don't really
know if there's a correct answer but
which AWS certification is right for you
you know when people ask me this
question like you know which AWS
certification is right for me how do you
provide advice on you know whether they
should start with Cloud practitioners
Solutions Arctic associate or maybe
another certification
okay so the linchpin or the actual uh
the center point the focal point of that
question is it depends on your goals so
what is your goal um do you want to be
certified because you want to upgrade
your skill are you currently a fresh
graduate who wants to uh have a
um wants to enter the tech or fan
companies so it actually depends so uh
before I answer that question let me
share my story now my first ever
certification I actually took the AWS 35
solution architect associate exam the
very first version
zero in 2018 my goal back then yes yes
as mentioned I was Contracting I want to
become a Solutions architect why because
it pays over a hundred over one thousand
dollars per day gross per day in
Contracting no so it's a big thing you
know uh from again I'm a developer and
then I want to be an architect or an
application architect that is actually
my goal and apart from that I also want
to take the togaf certification so those
are in my uh whys right so for for again
it depends on us especially if in our
for this top chat you see here uh people
have different um uh even in different
countries
um certifications if you're a fresh
graduate probably if you want you can
take your thought practitioner uh the
essentials or code practitioner exam if
you're a developer of course you have
the developer associate and then move on
to devops if you want and then if you're
a network engineer of course you don't
have to do you know Solutions architect
or developer associate but you can take
the network uh AWS Advanced networking
specialty so it depends to different
people
so yeah you have to just focus on your
plan and of course you have to
orchestrate which certifications is
right for you probably you don't need to
take all the AWS certifications but
again it depends on your goal
makes a lot of sense yeah you know set a
goal and then work back is sort of it uh
usually the beginner one is the cloud
pack but you know if people have a
networking uh interest and they already
have some you know knowledgeable cloud
and networking maybe you know they can
do the networking certification and you
have resources for all of them right all
of them on tutorial serger
yes yes as mentioned we're in AWS uh
training partner so we also provide
those free courses that you can see in
skill skill Builder so they have AWS
Cloud Builder they have courses there
right it's also available on tutorial
platform since we're an AWS trading
partner and yeah of course again we have
the practice exams ebooks if you want to
use of our video courses with the has
Aunt has on Labs yeah it the resources
are quite quite plentiful I would say it
depends on of course your
um your motivation to succeed so yes
nice okay
um sometimes people ask me you know
which brings us to the second question
is an 80s certification enough to land a
job so I did actually make a video about
this on my YouTube channel where I said
it really depends
um you know it's not enough necessarily
to give you all the skills to land a job
but it's a really really good starting
point uh you use that as a starting
point to then build hands-on experience
to then you know put that on your resume
build some Cloud projects and then
demonstrate to the employee that you
have the nest the relevant skills to
start on the job uh but what is all what
is your perspective on this do you think
um AWS certifications are enough to land
a job and if not would you recommend uh
students or Cloud Learners do on top of
getting a certification to then land a
job whether in AWS or through
Contracting and freelancing or you know
other ways of employment
sure
um so before I answer that
um I'm an employee and I'm now an
employer so I do have uh around around
10 staff here in the Philippines I also
hire the fresh graduates or and of
course um experience once experienced
folks so there's two different
perspectives I can provide you a
perspective on employee any perspective
of an employer like me or from like
myself so first and first most uh of
course they'll say oh we don't need
certifications because you only need
experience right oh yeah I have 10 years
of experience two decades of experience
or even three right however as you know
experience may not be enough let me
repeat that it may not be enough let me
give you an example
um let's say you're working on a company
big company and working today for 10
years now you're only constrained on the
Technologies of that one company
probably yes you can do let's say IBM
web servers or probably a Java or j2e
something like that right and yeah for
instance you can of course you have your
ec2 instances and everything like that
but again you're constrained in one
company or on your own one set I have to
believe me because I've been working uh
for as mentioned 12 different companies
different contracts and short-term
contract long-term contract and so each
company is quite different each company
have their own set of architectures
right so so going back to the question
is an ew certification enough to land a
job I would say it can give you that
advantage that advantage to stand out
firmware peers again if if there's a job
that pays a thousand dollars per day do
you think the employer will like okay uh
there's two employees here they both
know Java they both know everything so
what's the
um the thing that stands out what's the
competitive advantage of one person of
course if we have a certification you're
almost the same but you have the
certification you have the advantage you
raise from the bar right and of course
from from okay so that's the employee's
perspective and the employers protecting
uh as an employer I would say I even
hired like a fresh graduate right I
heard that guy actually uh well uh
actually direct now he became he became
an AWS Community Builder as well as
Jerome pocket but back then he's a fresh
graduate and everything because it took
an awvision exam he's a cloud
practitioner uh certified I hired him no
uh why because out of you know there's a
lot of companies or even employees
a lot of employees that they actually
have the same set of skills
so what's the difference how can you
know how can how can that person that
I'll choose help my company more right
so of course uh I'll be partial to that
person has uh certification of course
again it's not a okay a quote-unquote uh
um it will ensure that you have the job
right to land the job but it can provide
you that Advantage so think about it
just the advantage
makes a lot of sense uh you know when
you look at a resume it's like someone
who has a certification they can
demonstrate that they know AWS uh versus
someone who doesn't have a certification
but then again acidification uh two
people with a certification they might
prefer one who has previous experience
so I get what you're saying is it's not
an easy question to answer because you
know there's so many different factors
um
if I may ask yeah you actually uh an
ex-employ former employees Amazon do you
have a certification back then when they
hired you or
so my situation was a bit different I
started off as an intern at AWS and I
was in a non-technical team so they
didn't require any Cloud skills or
technical skills because the work I was
doing uh was more on the sales
enablement side rather than the
technical side so uh for me I did it but
what happened was before I transitioned
from becoming an intern to an associate
Solutions architect I thought to myself
okay I need to upskill my cloud skills
because I know that they give me some
time to
um you know like build my technical
skills during my first few months of the
role but I want to I wanted to you know
build my skills before then during my
internship so that's why I started my
certification journey to prepare myself
for the solutions Arctic role and I
would say it was really helpful because
when I started the job a lot of the
things started making sense like it
started actually clicking in my brain
like it made sense because a lot of like
the theoretical knowledge and the things
I'll do like build Hands-On like bits
and pieces it actually or just a form
together and like you know make yeah I
think it just it just made sense
essentially when I started building
actual Cloud projects and build them
most for customers I was like oh I you
know I've come across this before I've
come across this service I know what
this service does
um so yeah from my perspective
certifications you know not just enough
you know not just a factor for your
resume but also can help as a starting
point for your Club learning uh yeah
thanks for the question John next
question we have I like to go to the
audience now a few people have asked us
some questions so
first question is how do you transition
from an established on-prem
virtualization admin role to Cloud
position without starting over in an
entry-level job so I get this question a
lot sometimes people come from different
Industries within Tech
um like they might come from like a
on-prem background but then when they go
into the cloud industry they don't want
to start off as like a junior role or
like an intern uh do you think that's
possible without having to start over
um yeah just allows to get your opinion
on this
I would say so the question is uh for
this person doesn't have a cloud
experience right but only on-premises
experience right so like uh servers
probably routers and switches MRI
so it doesn't it I would say and I'm not
I'm very optimistic guy you know uh yes
you can it depends on again your focal
point your goal and your uh your
indomitable Spirit to take your goal so
I I
um in my experience now
um the reason why
um I'm quite optimistic is because I've
seen the job market sometimes they can
hire people okay okay let's go
um even though you're not really
qualified 100 qualified if the price is
right promise okay I think it's just
good enough already and it doesn't ask
for a high salary right I can train that
guy so for companies they have this
mindset okay uh even though it's not you
know 100 uh you know knowledgeable or
even certified I can they have this
training program right and so yes
technically employers can even hire you
and even though you don't have that 100
uh skills but of course most companies
they need okay I need to I need
classification and everything but yeah
but um like what Linda Viva said right
yesterday on the live stream she
mentioned that you can learn from the
job it's actually very true right now
you know there's chat GPT like very good
machine learning and there's a lot of
again different able Services come along
the way that are not available two or
three years ago right I'll tell you uh
honestly you know it's a lot of
learnings to do so if someone told you I
am an expert in cloud computing uh you
have to take it with a bit of optimism
of skepticism because it's quite new all
of this are quite news like two or three
years old right so you have the
capability or the opportunity to learn
more both of these are new things and if
you've got if you have your hands on
your exercise or projects you can even
tell your employers hey I was able to do
this uh in AWS so again I'm not even
though I don't have corporate experience
but well I do have this uh well this
practice exam I have this uh um projects
that I can even showcase to you I have
this let's say pro bono pro bono work I
mean to say okay
um do you know this uh simple project
like freelance project or even a pro
bono meaning uh here's a the CEO of a
church or you have a
um let's say a non-profit organization
you've provided their website or let's
say mobile app or even any solution you
can even do that and you can present it
to your resume
I've done it actually
so yeah
the the just don't be bogged down with
ah what's this I'm not certified no you
have to take it no you have to take a
chance like I know uh you have to take
you know a shot you have to shoot
yes exactly
yeah that's very inspiring because I
know sometimes uh people think that you
have to come from like a linear pathway
in that you you know go from like Cloud
engineer to Solutions Architects or you
know like
um transition from cloud world to Cloud
role but you can actually go from
um there's a lot of people who come from
non-linear Pathways who then move into
the cloud so uh yeah yesterday was a
good uh yesterday we had a live stream
and that was some good uh existence yeah
[Laughter]
also
um another question we have from the
chat is do you need a good foundation of
networking skills you know when you
start off by you know start off with
learning cloud and this sort of ties
into the fourth question that we have on
the screen which is are there any
prerequisites with learning cloud like
is is there any barrier that people have
to learn coding first learn networking
learn any other technology before the
learn cloud or can they just learn Cloud
straight away
again
um it depends on the project this magic
face it depends you know
um of course if for example you have
like serverless application or Lambda
function a simple like that uh of course
you have a you have to Learn Python
right or even Java if you have an
elastic stock stack uh for but for this
one so uh if you want to take the AWS
certification exam there are actually no
prerequisite or you can take uh go
straight to the specialty if you want to
you can go straight for professional
there's no prerequisite
but for for this one in terms of
learning the cloud I would say
um of course just a foundational one uh
and everyone has Google right so you can
you can Google things or chat ask chat
gbt okay how to create a great way an
API or a websocket API that provides me
something like that uh I would say not
really prerequisite so okay so the
proper mindset is don't think this
prerequisite is a prerequisite a hard
you know a hard wall that you have to oh
I'm not oh I don't do that again yeah
you should have your uh spirit
indomitable Spirit you have this
um you know the Gusto that that uh the
spirit of hey I can do it I can learn
that because in reality even you know
even a professionals like us how can I
am you know how can I change this thing
or how can I uh uh find an item in Unix
sometimes even professionals have to
rely on Google you know it's obviously
forget about things
for example encoding right I need to
create a uh yeah maybe a Lambda function
or something like that sometimes you
have uh we're not perfect no for the so
again moving back the prerequisites are
not really prerequisites it depends the
I think the hindrance will be yourself
honestly because if all again the
information the resources are already
there honestly you just have to take it
you just have to be dot you have to be
don't be afraid and just try it and
everything will be miraculously uh open
the doors for you so yes that's uh this
thing coding coding wise none really
so the prerequisite is your yourself now
you have to be available you have to be
willing to learn and that's it
exactly
um especially starting off with
something like just the cloud
practitioner certification I know every
video course I've come across you know
even if there are new Concepts that are
introduced they will pretty much explain
it from the basics and if you don't know
anything if there's times like like a
complete unfamiliar as you mentioned you
kind of just learn on the job you Google
it use chat GPT you know a lot of it is
learning on the go
um even you know working people working
in tech for a couple years they will
still have to search things every single
day
um because there's new product updates
and new services that come up all the
time so really good advice there
um another quite another few questions
actually on people asking about you know
like the best career path to become a
devops engineer best career path for
networking Cloud engineer and then
um people asking if you need like a
college degree to land a job so I'm
trying to think uh how we can answer all
of these questions at once because they
have a common theme of how do you map
out your career Journey uh based off of
the role that you would like I know we
talked a bit about this before but do
you have some extra advice for people
who are asking when you know they
already have a specific role in mind how
they can map out their learning and
career Journey
sure
um so this is coming from me with uh
again work with 12 different companies
and three different countries so I would
say start backwards so look for example
if you're in Australia look for go to
seek.com.edu if you're in Singapore or
maybe in Asia job Street or probably
monster.sg if you go to Canada probably
work workopolis or something like that
in the U.S master as well or indeed or
dice.com so go to those job sites that I
mentioned and then look for the actual
um the job specification the job
requirements for example they need okay
I need uh usually you'll see there okay
I need a unique experience or python
experience or something like that so and
then on a piece of paper or Google
Google word doc you can okay map out
okay out of these 10 different roles uh
job postings those job postings the
common denominator is always SQ UL or
Linux experience
that the owner was saying so that's uh
that's how you start off no so then from
from there you will see the market you
will feel the job market hey lately
there's a lot of um uh jobs right now
that's uh asking for or looking for this
particular skill or this particular
certification right I used to do that
because I know um that's how you get a
thousand dollars per day salary
as a contractor of course uh that's what
actually what we do it's very popular in
Sydney
um yeah uh it's like it's quite normal
of course uh famous contract that's okay
foremost contract I'm always that's
actually my uh that's the reason why I
have like 12 different compasses because
after one contract for example they gave
me let's say 500 per day okay The second
contract with the 600 per day and then
second 700 it it goes on top on top
so that's the progression again you have
to understand the job market
yeah yeah exactly and it's there in the
job sites it's there so uh that's one
thing so again you can focus on that one
and even though of course you're
probably you don't want to shift jobs no
that's understandable but you also have
to take a peek once in a while if to
check your if your current skill is
still updated let me give you a story um
back on Sydney as mentioned I was a Java
developer right and of course we went to
Singapore I was working with a large
Bank uh called a creative article
corporate Investment Bank as a French
Bank create agricult and I was there uh
as a Java developer and you know typical
um bank it's quite uh we're still using
JSP or old that was in 2014. it's quite
old Java technology and then when you
moved to Australia like wait this
they're using Cloud right I was missing
out I thought that I would say I'm on
top of my game but in reality I was
actually
uh losing all of my you know my Edge are
actually ebbing away you know that's the
reason why
um you have to take a peek you have to
be cautious and you know uh it is you're
in the IT industry I think that's the
um I would say the bad thing for us you
have to always be upgraded and
everything no but the good thing is
um if you if you're and if you want to
to succeed really succeed uh and if you
want to really Mash uh smash that salary
cap you can you can really do it by
being proactive by learning a lot by
taking those certifications by having
that advantage that most people don't
have so again I'm a realist again I'm an
optimist but of course of course I'm
also an a realist and the real thing is
the job posting right if I posted an ad
basically in let's say windows job site
I actually have to pay
for the job ad right so believe me when
I say you have to focus on those job ads
job advertisement because uh companies
like us we actually pay for that one and
those things that you that they
mentioned that that I put there on the
job ads is actually the things that I
really need right so again the technique
that you can use in I think in almost
country in almost every country you can
do it and yes again yeah uh all you also
have that we have to be uh conscious of
the job market
yeah I really like that advice of you
know sometimes just looking at many job
descriptions and seeing the common
trends like maybe whether that's SQL
whether that's coding whether that's you
know some sort of cloud experience uh
just analyze the common theme to the
role you're interested in uh you know
and this applies to the questions of
people who want to be devops engineer
network engineer analyze the job
description look for the common Trends
and then try and upskill in those areas
uh yeah really great advice there they
actually do you remember there's a
movement right now or probably in some
use they say devops is that
oh that's okay because there is now a
platform engineering right can you see
that yeah and then what so it's like a
reminiscent of uh of my of my experience
as a Java developer
is dead oh my God
why why is it dead that everyone
comments it's because there's no one
wants your skill no company wants your
skill why don't you know not know that
because you're not checking the job
market so again um you have to be
um but of course there are certain
skills that won't go away for instance
uh Linux skills SQL skills of course
those are the foundation of the of cloud
computing right uh so if you want in the
schools on those things that don't
really change a lot let's say Lino SQL
and and such and then after that
um but won't depend on one one line if
you want this one to be like a full
stack developer feel free to do so
because if you're a full stack I mean
you can go full stop meaning you can
take the programming front end back end
and everything that means the the
likelihood of you getting kicked out of
the company or having no job is quite
minimal because you can do front end or
back end however if you only do in the
front end let's say you say say angular
for example angular 5 and then that
specific uh JavaScript framework died or
there's no demand at all you're in big
trouble right or even for cloud right
just in case AWS they're saying their
sales or something like that no you have
to to Really uh have that portfolio of
and the skill set relevant skill set
relevant skill set yep that flows on
really well to another question that we
have in the chat which is what are the
hot it skills that are worth learning
apart from cloud I know we talked about
some of the foundational ones that will
be around for a while um what are your
thoughts on are there any you know if
someone was learning I.T and learning
cloud in 2023 what should they focus on
like what are the skills that they
should be like focusing their
preparation on
sure
um so aside from the things that you
mentioned like Lino SQL and every those
those foundational skills that you have
but of course get it flow and everything
uh in my opinion my personal opinion I
would say learn machine learning that's
one trendy thing because as you know
it's like after the chat GPT and the
news right it it actually trumps a lot
it means the If someone knows how to
wield how to program with machine
learning they will hire right because
right now it's
um I would say remember as a developer
right uh when I used to interview uh
okay do a create a program something
like that right right now it will be
obsolete those programming tests would
be opposite because someone I can just
type Jack gbt okay create me uh give me
a Fibonacci Sequence a program that
creates a Fibonacci Sequence that can be
just one night in chat gbt and it will
be pasted to the programmer so you know
uh uh in terms of programming it's
actually quite getting easier right now
right of course our platform engineering
and everything and for everything it's
it's um sometimes the the over it's
quite uh different now it's become
easier so the thing I think direct I
think uh for a complex right now is how
can you uh make or or use the machine
learning
those cost Concepts to in for instance
lower the cost of uh of infrastructure
yes uh saving money and saving money and
even creating more money to provide
Solutions so those things so again
machine learning that's one thing and
the good thing about it is
um it's foundational it's the machine
learning is basically funded with with
math right you have statistics you have
so math doesn't change the way it
doesn't you know it's constant right so
if you want to learn machine learning
you can learn the basics we actually
have a course in tutorial studio if you
want um fundamentals for machine
learning yes um yeah that's one thing
the other thing is
um actually
um for 2023
again you have JavaScript and everything
it really depends on your goal again on
your career career path so I would say
uh going back to the one that I
mentioned check the job market no
because it depends I can say Okay learn
to react learn what else uh floater
flutter learn those bunch of the
Technologies now but it really depends
on your goal
yeah let's take a step back into AWS
certification land because we have a few
questions now about you know people who
are studying for certifications I think
someone has uh they mentioned they have
a certification exam coming out tomorrow
so if we can share some tips with them
that'll be great and then afterwards we
can go back to talking about Cloud
careers and uh some you know you can
share your tips on freelancing
Contracting and side hustles which I
think will be really valuable so for
everyone watching make sure you stand to
the end for those tips uh but for 80s
certifications John you know you're a
leading certification practice exam
provider and now you're offering video
courses so you're really familiar with
this space and you've seen a lot of
students pass their certifications and
you know go on that Cloud Learning
Journey what are your tips on how people
can Ace their next certification exam
are there any learning tips that you can
share with them
uh sure
um the first and foreign first and
foremost you have to read the exam guide
the official exam guide from AWS it
contains all the information you need
okay so it's free again uh that exam
guide you can just search for example if
you're uh preparing for AWS
certification exam for social architect
essay the c03 exam guide just Google it
and then you will see the exam guide
right on that exam guide you will see
the information there right and then the
list of uh task statements okay so for
example for uh let's say search
architect I you need to learn how to
implement High availability Solutions so
of course you have to and then there's
like a sub statements there that you
have to focus on so this will be your
syllabus you know but you know back in
college right you have this syllabus of
the the things that you have to uh to
learn on that specific course right so
that is your guide now that's another
thing uh if you go further down you'll
see the appendix the appendix section uh
lists down all of the related services
so for example you will see there okay
AWS license manager oh you don't know
that there's a lot of there's actually a
list of AWS services that you can focus
on right and then there's another one
there's a uh list of not related AWS
services so for example uh Amazon Cloud
code whisper this is not uh so you can
you can you don't need to uh read about
that so again that's the uh that's your
Bible that's your source of Truth
and the next
um you have you can you can do your
practice exams or video course or AWS
documentation but again it's always
changing right even you know I can say
oh you take my video course take my
practices out no no no I always say that
but you have to believe the official AWS
certification
um the that guide and the AWS
documentation because that's the source
of truth right so AWS documentation read
the FAQs of course with the user guys
and documentation and then
um finally if you're done do your
Hands-On handsome Labs um you can even
create your own website right and then
when you're creating your website of
course you can create it in light sale
or in ec2 uh I suggest even had a he uh
put some certificates so you can
actually do two things no you can use
for your SSL you can use let's encrypt
if you want you know if you're penny
pinching if you want free ones or of
course you can also use the ACM awcm so
again
um for your certification exam it's also
very uh important that you know how to
uh uh to work on the AWS console
because sometimes you know um just
reading and just uh watching videos it's
not really enough no so it's not really
enough you have to to really try that
out and lastly in my personal experience
I hope I'm not biased because you know
I'm uh I also provide practice exams but
practice exams I would say it's it's
very important so for this one
um just just want to share now there's a
course in AWS skill Builder called item
writing
for smes so what this course is
basically it's it's teaching you how to
create uh practice exams item practice
exams what I mean is you know those
practice accepts actually created by
subject matter experts smes and this one
they're actually quite knowledgeable
some
um those practice exams I actually I was
even offered to to be an SMB and for AWS
certifications but no
um but for this one what I'm what I mean
to say is those practice exams is really
helpful because it's quite different
from just doing Hands-On just watching
videos honestly because it will uh the
thing is for those uh for this
particular questions you actually have
two questions
um so we have probably the primary
question and then you have the secondary
details right and then on the options
you have uh two or more related answers
you know in the cloud uh for example I
want to store my let's say I want to
store my any pictures you know you can
store it on an instance intern store on
EBS or probably in S3 or even probably
in a database if you convert to base64
you know there's a lot of uh there's
different ways to do a specific task
right but there's a certain uh you know
there's a certain uh school of thought
or certain strategy or certain uh
um uh there's a best practice in doing
so so of course if you
um for example for instance you store
your uh your pictures in in the store If
you restarted your virtual machine it
will be gone it's ephemeral right so
it's not the best case if you install it
in EBS yeah so of course uh even though
if you restart stop your EBS instant or
your instance it was still the same
however if that availability Zone uh
there's an outdation that available this
own your data will be unavailable right
so what's the best case it should it
should uh store it in S3 right so you
see some in this particular instance
that's the reason why practice exams are
quite very important because it will
help you to have that proper mindset
that you cannot do for if you just do
your hands on or your video course no
you have to have that specific mindset
I would say it's like a playing the
piano right do you play the piano or
musical instrument Lucy everyone I used
to not anymore but yeah we have this
major Keys minor Keys even accidental
kiss right you have the pattern for
example if you want to you know some
raps okay uh what's the chord so G B
minor CD or something like that or G
um E minor C this is a pattern right
there's uh so in in Surf AWS there's
also a pattern that you have to do for
the blues right any musicians in the
house you have just a lot of seventh
seventh key right uh so of course uh you
have the different uh techniques in
music that you can even Implement your
AWS in AWS is also patterns usage
patterns that you have to know so for
instance again if you want uh durability
you can put it in S3 if you want of
course uh the most cost effective it's a
keyword most cost Effective computing
solution of course you have to go with
fargate and Lambda right there's a
pattern right there's a pattern
um so those are the things things
um that
um that you can focus on and again uh
for the practice exam actually this way
I like it no uh for is for instance
um lately I've been working on with our
Advanced networking specialty practice
exam I really like it because whenever I
create a scenario right how what's the
difference between a Dean uh around 53
resolver Dean is firewall between an AWS
Network firewall
those are two uh two Services right uh
Route 53 resolver DNS spiral in another
one at the AWS effect firewall and how
about the firewall manager or how about
the guard Duty no it's quite um it's
very interesting to note so you really
have to to find the proper solution for
for your uh for a particular scenario
yeah really good advice
um I think practice exams was really
helpful for me as well
um back then when I was yeah doing I did
five certifications during my
certification Journey um and yeah
practice exams I think a lot the most
when I got questions wrong because you
know when I got it wrong and I look at
the answers there's a whole list of
explanations on you know why answer a is
correct but the rest are wrong so uh
it's a lot of just make making a lot of
the mistakes that you would make in the
practice exams so that when it comes to
the real exam you don't fall for the
same traps or like you know the same
sort of you know sometimes Services
might look very similar but they have
like little details or little features
that you know are different so it's
really good to learn that through kind
of like trial and error through through
making mistakes in the practice exams
um so yeah uh Hands-On practice exams
watching videos a combination of the
three would be really good uh during the
cloud Journey
need experience something like that I
would say again let's go in about going
back this uh exams are actually created
by subject matter experts from from the
U.S or so and I really like it because
um really those scenarios actually I
could even implement it I even
implemented some of them on my on my
startup no uh we're actually I wrote a
story before uh this startup the
tutorial Studio that we have uh for the
past like almost last year we have
almost zero AWS bill it was civil bill
because we have a lot of credits and of
course we were able to uh leverage on
the serverless technology and everything
so it's it's massive you know and those
um of course scenarios or the
certifications it will have the proper
mindset for you because again no again
experience is not enough I would say
because it might be concentrate on your
specific company only so you have to
think bigger uh to be honest no that's
why I like I know I like this uh the job
this uh this particular business is
because it it opened me to a lot of uh
it's like Pandora's Box a lot of things
that are open to me it's like what's
pilot light or what's the you know the
the seven artists of uh migration and
there's there's a lot of uh things going
on
um I didn't even know right so for this
one in terms of solutions architecture
in terms of you know um yeah and
everything even creating a business a
profitable business that's actually a
gift that AWS provided me and another
thing no I actually even applied for
Amazon web services yeah and then for
this one I was uh yeah I applied there
and then I even saw there you know for
the SD any SD position and you know what
uh one of the questions there is of
course you have the coding coding
exercises coding tests then the second
test would be of course the Amazon
leadership principle and the last one is
actually how to
um it's like
um there's a task there that says okay
uh build me a Twitter or build me a an
Instagram or build me a tick tock so for
this one there's a question there in of
course in AWS uh interview and then you
have to come up with those Solutions
architecture
so again if you know this is all of
these things oh oh yeah I can do it as
you need the cost effective I can do it
in Lambda and then of course you can
have uh use Amazon's Cloud functions to
make a customized CD and logic and
everything like that again the
certification is not just for your
career it can also be helpful in some of
course job job interviews yeah so yes
pretty much that's it
foreign
a lot of questions of that we've been
asked again around uh you know like I
think you know when you mentioned about
the 1000 USD a day uh that was pretty
cool and people were asking how do you
land a Contracting job how do you land a
freelancing job uh so I think this
brings us to the final question uh for
today's session which is how do you
improve your Cloud career in 2023 uh
which is what we have on the screen but
more specifically you know aside from
just applying to a traditional job let's
say within AWS or within the cloud
provider or you know in a full-time job
what are some other ways you know you
that that you can like earn money
through AWS
that is like not directly through a job
yeah yeah actually just a lot uh for
example YouTube yeah and you can like
Lucy's doing right now she of course are
providing information helpful
information for for everyone so what you
can do is just YouTube right
um You can even become a vlogger or
probably Tick Tock I would say tick tock
um the future yeah
even right now but it's actually crazy
Tick Tock is uh growing rapidly and you
have a lot of viewers now so if you want
you can also do that you know earn Tick
Tock money and what else AWS IQ so
there's a program in um applications
um adobe's IQ can uh us launcher
certified you can get uh contracting
jobs or freelance jobs that's another
thing it's only available in certain
countries uh but you can try it out what
else um you can even uh do a probably
well for instance no um
if you want to be an instructor it can
be an AWS authorized instructor so
that's another thing if you want to have
a side job of an AWS instructor you can
also do that and actually there's a lot
of things in in that you can do you can
even create your own business if you
want to
um first for instance if you have okay
you have this of course you can do it in
in freelance mode or if you want you can
create a solution your own solution
using AWS services so actually that's
what I did no uh well again a lot of
tourist Studio was uh already existing
back then but uh I actually uh changed
the business model for the tourist Dojo
uh we focus on the cloud right so again
we became a cloud provider and
everything like that now so it's
actually or for instance even right now
we want to move out to training right we
can even you can be a training partner
for instance or even uh you can have
your own contract job it can be a main
contractor and then you can subcontract
uh uh several people under you and then
get a you know a contract from the
government
if you're if you know a contact for that
one or a corporate so I'll say the
opportunity are endless
no it really depends on you yeah so
that's why the reason why earlier this
uh in their talk it depends on you you
have you have your heart you have your
indomitable Spirit or whatever you know
yeah it's true you have to be you have
to be biased bias in action so don't be
you know uh Paralyzed by okay I don't
know this no so those are the things uh
another thing I would say
um in the chat I see Stephen senet hello
hello there it can also be there yes
Community Builder be active in the
community right um so for this one you
can gain
um of course a connection to your fellow
like a professionals or even strike a
deal I believe that yeah so again the
possibilities are endless so you have to
be biased uh for Action right you don't
have to be idly oh oh the super
prerequisite uh no those are just CDs
yeah you have to try it out no so yeah
um that's my yeah that's my piece of
advice it's always
um for me I'm a well I'm a realist but
of course I'm very Optimist in the
future because I I know I can do it like
okay I'll do it I'll take a shot you
know so whatever you do I just take the
shot so first for instance there's a job
opportunity right now I'm not I don't
think I'm not qualified but just uh put
on the very beautiful cover letter uh uh
modify your resume to fit on the job
description and then just apply so again
I can't I get stress this enough but
just just do it
yeah I'm really glad you're sharing this
perspective because it's not something a
lot of people tend to talk about you
know when it comes to Cloud Learning
because a lot of it is just on your
mindset and you know just making sure
that you don't have any self-limiting
beliefs and make sure you do your
research right because there are no more
jobs you can apply for there's
contracting jobs freelancing AWS IQ uh
you mentioned you mentioned like a whole
bunch of other AWS opportunities so
that's really amazing and some of them I
never really came across when I was at
AWS so it's really cool that there's
this huge AWS Community out there a huge
support system as well for everyone
who's learning cloud so yeah this really
exciting time to be doing 80
personifications learning cloud looking
for career opportunities in it uh so
John this brings us to nearly the end of
the live stream we're closing in on the
hour but as always I like to usually ask
people for their top three pieces of
advice that they'll like to leave with
all the viewers you know if if they can
just take three things from the live
stream what would it be
all right uh I think uh I'll be
repeating myself over and over again
about the spirit the part so I'll just
give a story right again I came from the
Philippines I was actually I was born in
the slums I was a squatter yeah some
people they were born in the hospital I
was born in the slums
you believe that yeah so my name is
actually my real name is John John
okay
it's a funny name in the Philippines you
know it's a cool name yeah yeah it's
like uh but I I have a I have a lot of
insecurities as well I'm not at all you
know I'm doing Contracting in Sydney but
I'm a five foot five you know I'm a very
small guy you know then so that's why I
have this uh you know this magic shoes
with me
like inches on my and my height you know
because I'm doing Contracting I'm
talking to you know Australians they're
quite tall in different countries I I'm
I'm dealt with a lot of bad hand in life
right but no I was able to succeed
because I am biased for Action so I
don't I won't take no for answer if I
know that I'm right if I know that I'm
willing to work for it right so for this
one again I was able to um again uh I
was able to break that salary cap in the
industry you have salary crap what's the
salary cap salary cap is it ten thousand
dollars per month is it twenty thousand
dollars per month with the grand though
it's right now I'm earning way more than
that because I'm not afraid to grab it
no because and I actually expect that I
expect that uh that particular success
in life why because I'm working hard for
it every waking moment I am moving
closer to my goal every waking moment
I'm choosing to move towards to make
again I hope I'm not I don't sound like
I know
but uh that's the reality you know you
have to hustle you have to hustle you
have to do it no you have to take a
chance so yeah you can see uh the cloud
is not for me or something like that so
you have to try it again or change
strategy and everything like that so
again I think uh different viewers here
no uh if you're living in Australia or
in the first world country you're in
good hands you know you don't either you
don't uh you don't you know have those
uh issues that we have in third world
countries now but again uh for third
world countries or the poor poor
countries every even poor in the
Philippines it's really your choice you
have to take a stand and I'm not even
saying it like okay do this you have to
take a stand you have to um you know try
it out uh if it's if it's okay okay uh
if if someone let's say okay you can't
do it or someone told you oh you can't
do it or you're it's online oh you can't
get a job because of your you don't have
a degree you know I even see people they
were able to get a job without without a
degree right you just show it up okay
they just took a chance and someone took
a chance on them so it's the the uh
believe me when I say I've seen it
already you know the opportunities are
endless no so you have to just take it
so final word of advice is yeah don't
forget what I said
yeah you know um another word of advice
I would say so subscribe to Lucy's
Channel I would say yeah yeah that's you
if you haven't done so subscribe that um
I would say it's a very good series of
uh helpful videos and everything like
that you'll learn a lot right uh from
Lucy and from the people around you the
the person uh the people that Lucy are
actually uh interviewing are very uh
really good high-class people and you
can learn from them so that's one piece
of advice so ensure that you subscribe
um
Stephen Senate the one of my fellow AWS
Community Builders are here
um try to join adobe's Community Builder
program oh first for instance you're you
know you're you know for that one reason
basically uh if you're an AWS Community
Builder if you're you need to have you
need to produce at least two two or
three articles or videos or something
like that so this is stepping stone no
so from that one from being an AWS
Community Builder probably you can be an
AWS hero or something like that but
whatever you do just don't be afraid
just uh just do it
awesome thank you so much John for
sharing your you know your life story
with us and then all the motivational uh
words of advice there's a lot of
comments uh saying that they're really
motivated now and they're feeling really
inspired so this is great this is what
we want for people you know at the start
of 2023 to be pumped up and you know
ready to you know really own their
career and work towards their career
goals uh which is amazing which is
amazing so thank you so much John uh
again for joining today and for those
who want to enter the free raffle uh you
know for the practice exams ebooks and
video courses this is your last chance
to scan the QR code and you know I'll
just drop a link down below and um so we
have a few questions asking uh people
asking where they can reach you like
where they can connect with you uh view
your resources so do you have a link
that we can share with the viewers
uh sure uh again all of our free courses
and of course premium reporters in this
in this link before to look forward to
your.com or of course you can also uh
reach me on LinkedIn just type John
Bonzer not John John Bonzer but John
Rosa yes maybe you'll see me there uh
you can give me a follow so yeah
yeah I just posted a link uh to your
LinkedIn just in case so cool thanks so
much John uh we'll talk soon then all
right thanks everyone thanks John
thank you